so viga hey Vega Vega Vega I'm looking
over your form to a hear a request for
additional apparatus or equipment within
the Street Fighter 2 tournament also
heretofore known as SF to Street Fighter
champion edition turbo at all um if I'm
understanding correctly you would like
to fight with a weapon hey I want I'm
sorry sorry can you take that mask off
please
I want to use my cloud Jesus you you
want to fight with this claw Hey
okay that looks very dangerous yes all
my phone's went forward beneath his
mighty shower myth yeah I do believe
that if you go into a street fighting
tournament with an unarmed person they
would fall pretty quickly if you stab
them with three blades at the same time
is very powerful my cow okay stop with
the gesturing it's very deadly I have
full control over my phone
see that I'm sorry that is so mortifying
do you understand that could have been a
Honda's love-handle this is a
hand-to-hand tournament not a
hand-to-claw tournament we we have
brawlers kung fu fighters you want to
fight with the equivalent of three
butcher knives strapped to your fist I
mean the liability insurance alone on
that is is astronomical are you saying I
don't have micro yeah that's basically
what I'm saying is I'm denying your form
to use a Clow
but I need my cow it is an integral part
of my Matador fighting style Oh judge
it's your fighting style see and it says
here you also want to fight with that
mask you have and why why do you need it
because I must protect my beautiful face
okay why not just wear a full suit of
Knights armor hmm or just ride into the
arena in a tank tank would be actually
very useful oh my god I would be the guy
we see tanks Einstein and leap by leap I
jump I punch tank what okay so not to
the tank but may I still use my clothes
okay listen to what you're asking right
now you want to go into an arena with
chun-li
unarmed woman and stabbed her you want
to roll roll roll roll stab she drops
dead
that's a liability nightmare it's a PR
catastrophe it's a note but studying is
how I find I stay with my Chlo I protect
my face with my mask these are the
things I make Vega Vega also I am very
sexually hope okay nope
Vega listen if you want to gas and
straight-up mall people with blades
maybe maybe this isn't the tournament
for you maybe I could suggest Mortal
Kombat same floor two doors down talked
to Vern you can kill people tomorrow
maybe I will doctor he's firing oh good
yeah well well good luck fighting
sub-zero if he wins you're going to be
standing there for a minute then he's
going to rip your beautiful head off
with your spinal cord dangling down so
good luck good luck with that
I like your big braids by the way does
your father keep you locked inside of a
tower are you waiting for the right man
on his team can you hear this are you
waiting for the right man on a steed you
cheater